oh my goodness we've got a fresh bit of
maths research well from 2019 i consider
that
very recent all things considered about
gaussian integers rings finite fields
and the magic square of squares and so
uh for some of you that's a bit of a
spoiler on where parts of this video may
be going some of you may know the parker
square this is a fan sent this in if you
don't know what the parker square is
that's great to hear i don't want to
call it the parker square because it
doesn't work properly it would be like
oh that's a
classic parker square we'll get to this
content in a moment uh first of all i
really want to focus on finite fields so
a field is a bit it's like a generalized
version of what is a number in terms of
you can multiply it you can add it and
very importantly you can find its
inverse so for example the numbers the
real numbers are a field because if
you've got any if you've got a number i
don't know a and you multiply it by b
you're going to get exactly the same
thing as if you've got b multiplied by a
which means that they're commutative and
there will exist some number the inverse
of a so if you multiply a by 1 over a
then you get 1. so that's a
multiplication inverse and so for any
number if you had for example f of 4
and then you multiply that by 0.25
then you get 1 and very importantly
this is a real number
this is a real number and so every real
number has a buddy
real number where if they multiply
together you get 1 which means you can
undo multiplication it means you've got
division
and you're off and racing and you can do
this for all sorts of cool things you
can do it like i said here for the real
numbers you can do it for complex
numbers uh you can do like some
polynomials if you want to go wild
rationals the field is wide open so i'm
trying to say except
the integers
the integers don't work
very sadly big fan of whole numbers
everything else is great you can add
them you can multiply them and if you
multiply them because the other thing i
should say if you multiply two of them
together a times b
and you get some number c
that is also a real number or it's it's
a member of the field so the field's
closed there's nothing you can do in the
field
that will cause the ball
to land outside the field anything if
you're going to multiply your ad you
land somewhere else in the same field
very important and you've got this here
whereas integers that works you multiply
two integers together
you land somewhere else in the field of
integers
but you cannot find
an inverse a whole number inverse for an
integer so that means they get kicked
out
unless
you
shrink the field a bit so instead of
having the infinite
uh as let's say there's infinitely many
integers there's a big infinity of real
numbers instead of having
too much space we want to we want to
narrow this down a little bit if you
have a finite field
suddenly your integers are back on the
table
and you can have inverses of whole
numbers
provided the field is finite you know
what let's um very quickly put together
the addition and multiplication grids
for a finite field across some integers
so uh brady do you have a fun
prime number and i should warn you the
bigger the prime you name the longer
this is going to take don't go trivial
don't
i miss your seven seven that's nice that
that's neat and tidy so what we'll do is
surface seven we're gonna effectively be
doing
modular arithmetic on mod 7. and so what
we're going to do is let's do
multiplication first and i'll very
quickly fill in this table so we're
going to multiply
here we go
we're going to multiply
as if this is a grid so one times one is
one let me this is a super boring column
this one's not much more exciting so two
times one two two twos are four
six ah now this this should be eight
mod seven
one
and so here we should have ten so that's
going to be three and here we should
have twelve so it's going to be five so
i'm taking whatever you get when you
multiply these i'm getting the remainder
mod seven so i'm dividing out any sevens
it's just the leftover bit
and we can do the same thing for
addition but we add them and we take the
mod seven and we loop back now at this
point a lot of people thinking well hang
on why are you getting so excited about
finite fields when you're just doing
modular arithmetic that doesn't count
well it's not 100 true so i would call
this this is like the the integers
uh so z
weird z for the integers uh kind of mod
7 gives us this
this doesn't work for any number you
don't get a finite field
which is why i said prime it only works
for
primes and powers of primes
so
you will get a finite field for the
integers mod 7 you'll get a finite field
for the integers mod 49 so that's 7
squared or mod 25 because that's 5
squared or whatever the case it doesn't
work for the in-between values now i've
never tried this
but i thought it might be fun
just to see what happens when it breaks
so let's break it let's brady you want
to pick a number which is not a prime
and is not
a power of a prime
and then we'll we'll try to do the same
grid and we'll see we'll see why it
breaks
6 6 excellent because that's 3 times 2
it's not a power of a prime it's got
more than one prime factor is the other
way of saying that so so this is going
to be fancy zed
six
okay so i should point out i i've kind
of hidden zero because a whole row of
zeros is even less exciting than um
having these
and zero doesn't get inverses and all
that jazz so we ignore zero now so you
think well this is perfectly good why
doesn't this count as a finite field
well it's because we've haven't got our
inverses so if you ever look over here
all the numbers we might have all the
non-zeros one through six one has an
inverse it's one because there's one
here two has an inverse
it's four so if you multiply two by four
mod seven
you get back to one so technically a
half
in
the finite field
seven
is four
so
that checks out uh three a third is five
because 3 times 5 gives you 1 and then
there's one there and there's one there
and there's one there and so quite
nicely there is a 1 in every single row
and there's a one in every single column
as you set up here we have to be able to
achieve one somehow yes you have to
multiply to get to one and you can't do
that with regular integers but because
you've got mod it means you can loop
around to get back to one because
otherwise once you once you're gone
you're not you're not coming back to one
whereas now
loops back however
sometimes
you never hit the one so there's a
there's some ones in this grid but look
at this 2 hasn't got a inverse there's
nothing you can multiply 2 by to get
back to 1 mod 6. and so that's why this
one is ruled out it's still nice still
modular arithmetic
big fan
it's not a finite field and finite
fields then linked to all other amazing
things and loads of abstract mathematics
you'll be looking at
fields and finite fields which are great
and finite fields have allowed for a
breakthrough in an area of mass very
close to my heart when i first read a
paper i'm just kind of
glancing through it i'm not checking
through all the details i just want to
get a sense of what they're doing and
you know what i do and don't understand
and then what really jumped out at me is
section five here the smallest
non-parker finite field it turns out
they're now using my name
that's me i'm parker
as a type like a a property that finite
fields can have in fact you can put all
finite fields into two categories you
can put them into the parker finite
fields and you can put them into the
non-parker finite fields and a very good
question might be
which is better
and very sadly
a
a parker finite field means it doesn't
work it's like the dad it's the dud
finite fields when they're growing up
what do you want to be
when you're exactly the same size
because you're finite and they say
i hope i'm non-parker that would be the
dream to be a non-parker finite field so
i've got a thing named after me i'm
afraid your field has been diagnosed as
i'm the phrase parker
it's not curable the condition of being
parker
oh and they've used uh fancy f to mean
finite field mod 29 for example is not
parker
since here
and then they've given a magic square so
for everyone who's unfamiliar with
magic squares of squares this is a
really nice entry point so this is a
magic square
and it's got nine numbers in it and so a
magic square
if you want it to be properly magic is
if you add together all the columns you
always get the same total if you add
together all the rows you always get the
same total
and
people are really insistent about this
it turns out if you add together both of
the diagonals
you get the same a total and then you
can go insane you can do all these like
pan diagonals that wrap around but
people don't tend to put those in they
just care about both of those diagonals
that doesn't work for these numbers
until
we square them you now have a magic
square where every number in it is a
square number and it works hence magic
square of squares here's magic square of
squares now
this has one extra condition so so the
full backstory is i came up with a magic
square of squares because i thought it
was interesting no one had ever found
one and no one had ever managed to prove
that one doesn't exist which is still
true for the record so i gave it a go i
found this one now mine has the extra
condition it's not very good and that's
because it's got the duplicate numbers
so you can in fact it's symmetric which
is terrible and it doesn't add it
doesn't do all of them one of the
diagonals is wrong near miss and this
bend up the parker square and i don't
know who was responsible for this but a
line of merch came out
people started showing up to my shows
wearing t-shirts very few performers
have put up with being bullied by their
merch at their own gigs this one has a
condition as well
so it is it's got both diagonals it's
got every row every column except the
whole thing
only works mod
29
so this works on the finite field of
integers mod 29
we can we can check that i i would like
to do that and you can decide how much
stays in the edit
and now these are all mod 29 so anything
smaller than 29 doesn't budge anything
bigger than 29
so now
we need to go through and add these up
so we'll do the rows first shall we so
23 and 25 is 28 29 so if we come across
there add them up we get 29 this one
here we get 29. uh this one here you're
thinking whoa
it's gonna be bigger than 29
28 and 24 is gonna be 52
58
and you're like that's way too big well
actually 58
mod 29
well it's zero in fact all of these mod
29 a zero so actually if you add every
single direction you get zero
so it's a magic square of squares
where the magic sum is zero
so
that's a beautiful i don't know why i
find that so pleasing and look what
dross you served us up i died
i i was four years early like you can't
look like it's like looking at the
iphone 4 and going well that wasn't very
good yeah things have moved on
technology has advanced without this
this wouldn't be happening that's right
what a weird world we live in brady so
29
like that's a par that's a
non-parker field it's a non-parker field
because
within
the numbers
in
the finite field of order 29
there exists a perfect three by three
magic square of squares
and so any uh finite field where you can
make a magic square
of squares
is a non-parker finite field because it
works and then the rest of the paper of
this section of the paper this is really
quite nice they then go they go well
hang on okay we found this one and then
they say uh here's all the finite fields
with orders less than 29 and so you've
got a whole bunch of them here they're
all the primes and powers of primes
below 29. so now they found the one for
29 and the obvious question is is that
the smallest this is what you always ask
in math is it the smallest is it the
biggest and so
their first question was
is 29 the smallest finite field which is
non-parker so is everything below that
unfortunately resigned to being parker
and when you say finite fields we're
narrowing this search to the integer
finite fields obviously yeah yeah and
you could do magic squares with other
things check some polynomials in there
you could do complex in fact gaussian
numbers they're talking about earlier uh
when when you're looking at it um in the
complex space right so there's a lot of
fun you can have here's the deal they go
through they rule them all out
none of them are non-parker everything
below 29 is parker and so they managed
to show
comprehensively that this
is the smallest non-parker
finite field but then they turn and look
in the other direction
in general they suddenly realize
actually
most finite fields
are non-parker
because of the parker ones the ones that
don't work are quite rare and so here
it's a conjecture so this is not proven
but they seem pretty confident
the only parker fields of prime order
are these ones
and so it turns out any finite field
with a prime order of our friends the
integers bigger than 67
is non-parker all of them the infinitely
many prime numbers bigger than 67 all
have a magic square of squares
in there somewhere in their finite field
so
it turns out not working being a parker
is actually quite a rare um special
property prestigious
exactly bestowed upon very few
people and finite fields
get to have the luxury of being parker
because uh it's conjectured but i i'm i
i'm going to believe them because once
you go plastics they're all they're all
non-parker now the flip side to this is
you might say well what about
infinite fields like what what about the
integers which is what started this
whole thing in the first place
for the infinite field
of
um
integers well this is no longer
a field it's now it's a ring but let's
not it's it's no longer a field there's
infinitely many of them the question i
have is does this tell us anything about
finding the parker um square in general
or through the true the true yeah and
sadly we still don't know
so all they can say is
you can have arbitrarily large
finite fields
of a prime order and they will always
have a magic square of squares in there
they're all non-parker because they work
we still don't know
if a magic square of squares
just without needing to be mod anything
exists so still an open question and so
um
the research will continue i mean the
greatest minds in mathematics will
continue to turn their attention using
things like finite fields and any
mathematical tool at their disposal
in the soul like the greatest search in
maths is
are numbers parker
or are numbers
this discussion continues for a bit
longer in a bonus video on our extras
channel number file two
that's what is the oh my goodness we
never parker prize well what are the
other prizes out there there's like
millennium millennium fields that's a
bit rich
for more about what matt parker's up to
from live shows to books to his own
youtube channel stand-up maths check out
the various links in the video
description could we even communicate
with beings from a non-parker reality it
boggles the mind